a controversial convention has a new
home in las vegas after caesar's
entertainment canceled it earlier this
month the a hearn hotel will now host
the patriot double down a confirmed q
anon event or go mana join us live from
the property near las vegas boulevard
and sahara with more on these event
details orco
well brian the q9 conference will be
from october 22nd to the 25th here at
the ahern hotel whose owner is a huge
supporter of former president donald
trump those we spoke to say they're not
for the event and they are it's a mixed
reaction here in vegas
i think they're dangerous people heather
folked is upset a q anon conference will
take place next month at the acorn hotel
just south of where she lives 8 news now
has confirmed the property just off the
las vegas strip will host the forgotten
country patriot double down event
spreading a bunch of lies q on refers to
a far-right conspiracy theory that
falsely believes donald trump will
expose a group of satan worshiping
pedophiles and declare martial law folk
says she does not want anything
associated with this near her home look
what they did on january 6 trying to
storm the capital and kill people they
bring violence they bring hatred they
reinforce all of these white supremacist
ideals that is not okay the event was
originally scheduled to happen near the
forum shops at caesars but without an
explanation caesar's entertainment
pulled the plug on the conference some
say they're fine with the ahern hotel
hosting it everybody's entitled to their
own
their own situation as long as they
don't bother other people hotel owner
don ahern is the nevada republican
party's finance chairman and a major
supporter of donald trump don air and
he's probably just
trying to make money but folk says
that's no excuse cancel them don't allow
it to come into vegas we don't need that
here
we try reaching out several times to
both don ahern and the ahern hotel to
talk about the upcoming event but we
have not heard back from them yet
reporting live in las vegas tonight orca
mana 8 news now